all right joining me now is North
Carolina Congressman Dan Bishop who
voted against the bill and Wisconsin
Congressman Derek Van Orden who voted
for the bill so Congressman Bishop a few
minutes ago Joe Biden put out a
statement said this this agreement is
good news for the American people and
the American economy uh 165 Democrats
voted for it you opposed it uh is it
good news for the American people
Pete I think the indication in the vote
that more Democrats voted for the bill
than Republicans did and of course
Republicans have a larger number of
members in the chamber is a sign who got
the best of the deal and and that the
the benefits of the deal as sold by the
leadership have not they haven't been
square with the American people about it
biggest problem of all is the debt limit
by Kevin McCarthy's own initiative and
without the advance agreement of the
conference is stretched out a year
longer than we propose to do and the
incurrence of probably for nobody has an
exact number because they didn't specify
it in the bill they should have 4
trillion maybe more in additional debt
on the American people is to be incurred
without any opportunity to come again
and try to gain more in terms of real
and substantial benefits so it's a
missed opportunity obviously the biggest
problem it split the Republican
conference deeply and Now Kevin
McCarthy's got to figure out how we
reacquire the unity that we started the
year with after the as a result of this
contest for the speaker's election
I'm going to get to that I want to get
to that in a moment but representative
Van Orden are you concerned by we
thought maybe 35 or 40 Republicans would
vote against it the number was 71 on the
final vote are you concerned by the fact
that so many Democrats liked it and so
many conservative Republicans didn't
no I'm not I'm not at all Pete there's a
lot of people talking about what is not
in that bill but let's talk about what
is in that bill it protects the people
that built this nation those are our
seniors it protects the people that
protected this nation those are our
veterans it protects the people that
feed this nation those are our Farmers
by making sure that our biofuel
Industries remained viable and it helps
the people most in need in the United
States of America I'm on the snap
committee on purpose because I was
raised in poverty on in food stamps so
what this does is it allows these folks
to get back into the workforce because
we have real work requirements in this
bill for the first time in a very long
time and it allows people the dignity to
be able to support their own families so
no I'm not worried about how many
Republicans didn't vote for this I'm
sure that we're all going to get
together on Monday again and we're going
to work together as a conference because
that's what adults do governing is very
difficult and we're at it hard here in
the house
I'm curious real quick Congressman Van
Orden what did you hear from
constituents like on balance
um were they for against this was there
was there a sense in your office you
know what it was about 50 50. and the
reason being is that there's a lot of
stuff being put out by the uh Biden
Administration saying that veterans
benefits are going to get cut that was a
lie they're saying that Social Security
Medicare are going to get cut that was a
lie so a lot of the constituents that I
have were concerned about their benefits
I was with a 93 year old Korean War
veteran at an American Legion in Sparta
Wisconsin who was shaken to the core
because he thought he was not going to
get his veterans benefits and that's the
direct result of incredibly disingenuous
messaging by the Biden Administration
and it's unacceptable
[Music]
representative Bishop you talked about
Unity there wasn't a lot of Unity on the
floor tonight uh there are some that
have suggested yourself included that a
motion to vacate could become part of
this process are we at that point where
the man on the screen right now his job
is in Jeopardy because of the vote I
mean do you is Unity standing behind him
even if it you don't agree on everything
or is he got to be with you all the time
yeah Pete we're not going to agree on
everything that no one ever has in such
an expectation but we came to a
resolution of the our disagreements at
the beginning of the year when Kevin
became speaker around an agreement that
was specific in terms and it had certain
key components Kevin has violated one of
those in the negotiation he undertook
the the so that agreement produced until
now in amazing unity and the ability to
work effectively as a majority
that unfortunately has been damaged
badly or perhaps destroyed I think we
have to look now to Kevin and see what
his next move is to see if that can be
recovered uh a violation does one
specifically well there are specific
terms about that we that he would be
committed to reducing discretionary
spending to the 2022 levels that didn't
occur in its entirety in this bill and
furthermore we did although we spent all
these months having conferences and
staying in touch across the conference
to keep people in the loop here Kevin
Went off for the first time to do a
negotiation on his own and without
notice not only did he double the amount
of debt the nation was going to incur
before we get back into the negotiation
again he abandoned that core tenet of
the agreement and so that that at the
very least so are you saying today you
will or would you support them based on
what you know right now do you support
Kevin McCarthy as the Speaker of the
House well I I there's a there there's a
question that must be answered which is
what how does this get rectified I don't
think you just go forward after he's
abandoned the agreement that we entered
the uh Congress under and just hope for
the best I think it'll get worse and
worse because this because people were
so uh badly abused by the way the
negotiation was handled
representative van Orton last word real
quick I mean colleagues talking about
breaks and Trust what do you make of it
I think that Monday morning we're going
to get back together as a conference
we'll probably wind up drinking a cup of
coffee with my colleague Mr Bishop and
we're going to make sure that we work
for the people that represented us so
the 750 000 people of Wisconsin's third
congressional district sent me to
Washington D.C to work for them and this
bill worked for our seniors our vets our
farmers and those most in need I'm very
proud to support it and I have the
utmost confidence in Kevin McCarthy's
leadership this conference is going to
work together because we're all adults
and we're putting the best interest of
the United States of America over our
own personal interest and that's how
you're supposed to govern and that's
exactly what the the House of
Representatives is doing and we proved
it today
well the speaker made a deal and it did
pass we'll see what the future holds
Congressman bishop and Van Orden thank
you very much